hello everyone welcome back to the capo
Blanca saga were back at the 1914
tournament of son Peter Berg and
Capablanca faces Frank James Marshall
now a couple unka is definitely in the
lead when you consider how many times
the two of them have played as Cabo
Blanco destroyed him in the match part
of the 1911 census but stay on
tournament but here in the first part of
the 1914 son Peter Burke tournament they
drew the game it was a patter of defense
game Marshall also had the black pieces
and after some 35 moves they agreed to a
draw this time it's going to be the same
line but kappa blanka decides to mix it
up so couple monk are still having an
excellent tournament one and a half
point lead after the first part of the
tournament then a draw against World
Chess Champion Daniel asked her and
standing victory against dr. Siebert are
in round two this is Round three and
Capablanca goes for e4 we have e5 Knight
to f3 and now Marshall one of the few
people here that actually does not go
for for the rule opus but he goes for
the better of defense like he did in the
first part of the tournament Knight
captures with d6 this is the main line
of the petrov nine three and Knight
captures on e4 and here in the first
part of the tournament Capablanca went
to d4 marshall replied d5 this is still
the the classical line which is played
even today and Capablanca decides not to
go for it this time as Marshall had a
bit too much activity in the previous
game so he goes for Queen to e2 now you
have to block with Queen e7 if you play
something like this then d3 wins the
knight just attacking the pin piece so
after Queen e2 we have Queen to e7
and now d3 Knight to f6 and although
Capablanca does not mind exchanging
Queens he does not want to capture on e7
he wants Marshall to capture Ani
doso Capablanca would they develop his
pieces with tempo
Bishop to g5 Capablanca continues
developing Bishop to e6 Marshall also
isn't interested in helping Capablanca
develop Knight to c3 and now just h6
Bishop captures Queen captures and d4
capablanca gives up the bishop pair but
he has a different ideas about this game
now if you look at couple uncas pieces
it sure does seem like Capablanca is
ready to Castle queenside and this is
what
Marshall has in mind he plays Bishop to
be special 3/7 and he doesn't mind this
Queen b5 check which the idea of losing
the b7 point because Marshall and with
the idea of Capablanca castling
queenside would actually enjoy the semi
open B file to attack up a Blancas king
but capablanca goes for it Queen b5
check
we have 937 and now Veronica doesn't
capture the b7 pawn it could be somewhat
too dangerous for example if Queen
captures okay the rook is under attack
Ruby 8 attacks the Queen Queen captures
giving up the second phone and then just
castles and now for example if you do
Castle queenside it would be too
dangerous and if you try to Castle
kingside now then rook F c8 attacks the
Queen you give up the third pawn but now
Luke captures here removes the defender
of the night and Cora Blancas king is
still stuck in the center of the board
with marshal species you know ready
ready to just march forward so could be
could be a bit too dangerous Capablanca
decides for Bishop to d3 now leaving the
option of Castle King side but also
castling queenside we have g5 by marshal
now if complete Lanka das Castle
kingside Marshall is already prepared to
attack even on the Kings side and here
acabou Blanca prevents any further
pushing of the points with h3 it's a
very nice idea because now g4 h captures
Bishop captures doesn't work due to
Knights to d5 attacks the Queen and also
threatens Knight captures on c7 which
would deliver this very nice fork but
it's still a nice it's still a nice idea
after Queen e6 check you have to go kink
to f1 still the threat remains and now
after black the castles Queen side you
get rook to e1 and now the rook and
Knight will win the bishop on e7 white
wins the game so that's the idea
if marshal is you know just crazy and
wants to go for g4 immediately but okay
here at marshall castles King side and
only now that Marshall castles King side
Capablanca decides to grab the b7 pawn
bits because it's actually an attacking
move Queen captures on b7 and now the
Queen will have a quick escape square
because after the rook attacks the Queen
Queen efore will also as the bishop is
on d3 threaten checkmate on h7 so Queen
captures on b7 we have
rook a to be eight and now not going for
further material but rather Queenie for
threatening Queen to h7 checkmate now
Marshall has two ways to move to you
know prevent checkmate Queen to g7 is
played and now just be three capablanca
stops any a pawn grabbing on the Queen
side and now just enjoys his extra phone
what does Marshall have for this extra
pawn well he does have a bit more
development capablanca skin is still in
the center of the board so maybe he can
do something about this he goes for c5
he wants to bust open the center
capablanca quickly castles and now C
captures on d4 we have Knights to d5 now
capablanca now wants to get rid of at
least one of Marshalls bishops and the
d4 pawn is a weak double pawn very soon
cover Blanca will also try to eliminate
that as well
Bishop to d8 for the moment Marshall
doesn't allow capturing or does he want
to capture here he wants to preserve the
preserve the bishop pair for as long as
possible
Bishop to c4 now and here comes Knight
the c5 here Marshall could go for Bishop
captures Bishop captures and Bishop to
f6 now to try and guard the d4 pawn but
capablanca can just go rook 81 with a
triple attack here and there would be
there would be no good way to continue
defending this pawn you could go
something like Ruby 4 but it doesn't
work you can just push the rock away
with a three rook would have to move in
there and just win the pawn so a marshal
decides for an active plan Knights the
c5 attacks the Queen and now just Queen
captures on d4 offers a queen trade and
here Marshall accepts Queen captures on
DeForest played Knight characters on d4
Bishop captures Bishop captures and now
bushel to f6 attacking the knight but
also the knight now cannot move as the
rook on a1 would hang rook eight d1
getting rid of both threats and now
comes Bishop captures on d4
rook captures on d4 the road the night
was now a bit more - a bit more powerful
than the bishop so Marshall decides to
get rid of it and King to g7 getting out
of this nasty diagonal and now if you
look at the position
what's the evaluation of the
well even without actually checking the
evaluation you can see that Capablanca
has six points and Marshall has five
points capablanca has two point Islands
this one and this one Marshall has three
point Islands so I definitely the guy
with the fewer porn Islands is is in a
better position and capablanca has a
bishop against a knight would play on
both sides of the board you know those
three little things are enough you know
for a couple of long had to push for a
more than a draw here Bishop to c4
attacking the pawn on d6 Marshall
defends that rook to be six and now rook
to e1 we have King to f6 morning to get
to the king to the other side of the
board with tonight's to e6 blocking D
file and then perhaps the King can go
behind the pawns but capablanca our bust
open the position with f4 with night the
e6 f captures on g5 with check-check H
captors and g5 and now rook to f1 check
King to e7 Marshall manages to get his
King to the other side of the board and
now troop to g4 prepares to grab the g5
pawn either by eliminating the defender
of the g5 pawn or in the other case
where a Marshall actually defends that
would rock the g8 now capablanca just
shifts all the pieces to attack the the
Jeep on we look here you can never push
f6 because then just the rook here will
be it will be too much so we have looked
the c6 now now Marshalls idea is that if
capablanca removes the defender of the
g5 pawn at least at the end of this
variation Marshall will grab the c2 pond
and he will have some counter play but
now capablanca just brings another
attacker towards the g5 pawn now how do
you do this as you don't have any other
attackers well you do have the H bond
and the rook on g8 is undefended
so h4 now there is no defense against
the g5 one but Marshall finds and
indirect defense to towards this rook G
to c8 now this is how Marshall does it
we have h captures and g5 and now look
the c5 the night and rook are again
pressuring this spawn and the rook on f5
is also under attack
so we have bushel captured by Capablanca
F captures and now rook captures on c5
rook captures on c5 now the rook the
pawn is under attack and now if the king
can for example get the g6 and win that
pawn perhaps it would be playable but
still black black can not afford the
trade rooks here being down being down
even two points but at least it's it's a
better position since couple Blancas
extra point is a GG pawn so here kappa
blanka pushes g6 he allows marshall to
grab the c2 pawn but grabbing the seat
opponent would be too slow if you play
rook captures and c2 than g7 and there's
no good way I mean there's no way to
prevent the point from queening so
unfortunately for Marshall he will not
be grabbing the seat upon today we have
King to f8 the King has to help out
would with the prevention of queening of
this pawn rook the c4 now by Capablanca
and this is a very interesting move
because it allows Marshall to create a
second pair of doubled pawns for kappa
blanka for example rook captures
captures it's interesting if this
endgame is not winning for white yes
white is up two points but those are two
doubles pawns so it's a very nice to
check we can just quickly check what's a
king g7 King if to kink characters King
III going over to the Queen side King a5
you go king d4 now you have to go a five
check King d v e4 King has that
prevented the bass pawn king to f4 now
comes a four and now let's say III the
King has to go to d3 and now you can see
that black is running out of moves but
can go a5 but that's just a temporary
move let's say c3 and now black is
really out of moves you can either give
up this pawn give up this point or move
the King as the d3 and d4 and every
squares are not available too so here
after let's say you go after the pawn
king captures captures King D for now
you'll grab this point and this point
will Queen so the the pawn ending is
winning here for kappa blanka we don't
do not want to trade rooks here but it
of course is important to check
sometimes your opponent will make a
mistake rook to a5 going after the a to
pawn and now comes a 4 just defending
everything so not a problem King to g7
by marshal and now
rip the c6 and now cover Blancas plan
was to give up the double pawn for some
nice connected passports in the center
rook to d5 defending but now comes Luke
the c7 check you can't defend everything
King chapters and rook captures an e7 so
capablanca managed to eliminate this a7
pawn and give up his double the G upon
which was not all that impressive rook
to d1 check we have king to h2 and now
d5 Marshall starts pushing in the center
with a 5 capablanca starts pushing his
own past pawn rook the c1 and now rook
to c7 defending the seed upon root K 1
attacking the pawn now comes before rook
to e4 attacking the be for pawn but now
just c3 and here marshal plays d4 he
wants to remove this pawn so the b4
point is undefended which makes sense
you always want to attack the base of
the pawn chain rook the c6 threatening
to win this pawn with check but now D
captures on c3 and now doing this would
be too much to allow black to have the C
troponin and also lose your b4 phone so
couple uncle goes for route captures and
c3 we have group capture some before and
now of course you don't know what to do
you have to put a rope behind a passed
pawn rook to a3 now the thread is of
course just Queen that pawn so Marshall
has to go back Ruby 7 we have a 6 to a 7
and now Marshalls rook is stuck guarding
the pawn here and the marshal will not
have all that many active moves he will
try to bring his King over to the Queen
side to help out with the defense so his
roof can perhaps be activated but let's
see let's see how he does
we have rook to a 5 by capablanca
gaining as much activity as possible and
also limiting the black King so he
cannot never cross the 5th rank we have
King to f6 now comes G for kink the e7
King g3 Capablanca also brings the King
into the game King d6
King to f4 we have King to c7 but now
just kingly 5 attacking the pawn and
Marshall is not in time to do anything
about this so he has to go back King D 7
we have G 5 now now kappa blanka is also
threatening the Queen the Jeep on king
37 we have g6 and now
King 2f8 the these words are taken by
the king and by the pawn so you have to
go to f8 if you go something like rook
e8 it's no better like everyone could
just pushes a7 and you will still have
to move the King and then it's just even
worse so Marshall tried moving the King
immediately but now comes King captures
on e6
now come on guys up two points without
any compensation for black King yet here
we have g7 so the easiest way to
continue rook can capture but you know
it's just it's just lost after that we
have a seven rook checks King King to a5
and now it was in this position almost
61 that Frank James Marshall resigned at
the game so there was no way to survive
this in game a couple gonca was always
better and I mean the position was
always winning it was just a matter of
technique how he would go about the end
game and Capablanca chose the the
simplest way to end it so yeah now a
very interesting game Marshall decided
to again go for the petrov as he really
enjoyed his previous game against
capablanca but Capablanca already
decided to mix things up in the
beginning of the game with that queenie
to check and marshall tried attacking he
tried to gain some initiative he tried
to give up the b7 pawn but it was only
after
capablanca was sure he could take it he
grabbed it and then threatened checkmate
and just you know i went in donating and
game being opponent so now that's how
Capablanca plays always makes it look
simple but you know when we play it it's
just never simple so yeah that's that
it's like that but yeah now I do hope
you enjoyed this game and that you're
enjoying the capablanca saga so far we
are almost over with with the 19:14
tournament in son Peter Berg and I
haven't decided where the saga will
continue from then from there but you
know maybe one more tournament before
the match would Lasker but we will see
yeah now I would like to thank Edward
got
garni Barca Darian Paul staples is
mussalam and Stefan 1 for a conversion
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos ER thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some new interesting
content and you know just checking up on
yours
Jess and you know following what's
happening in the world Sam I think all
and I will see you soon